well the the foundation for the  settlement of this dispute is a  guarantee of no compulsory redundancies  across the two sections of the industry  in network rail and the train operators  once we've got that we can move forward  we can discuss all the changes that  they've got on their agenda which are  difficult some of them difficult for a  union to deal with and difficult for our  members to adopt  at the same time we can talk about the  pace so there's a free  pillar settlement here job security  a discussion on conditions for agreement  and in a pay deal that addresses the  cost of living crisis in this country  and the fact that many of our people  haven't had a pay increase for two to  three years